i i i feel so bad
oh are we gonna get queenie four night
age four queen eight mate is ruby is
gonna see this oh ruby is ruby it's ruby
it's no
[Music]
rubios
rubius has played e4 and
all right c3 that might be preparation
yeah c3 d4 it's good preparation it's a
very good system the alapin
this is already actually quite
advantageous for for
for white isn't it yes and this is what
we expected we expected daniella to go
d6
daniel negrando absolutely must play the
move e6 right now
he hasn't and if if rubius realizes how
strong
e5 is anna and e6
just pushing through that that
i wonder if he senses it because uh
we've got the opening principles
right in terms of development and
counseling as soon as possible but
it's not that easy to know when it is
the right moment to strike i think when
you're starting out with chess that's
one of the most
difficult um to feel the right moment to
know when you should push
because the queen side of white is still
on develop c
so he could also think is it time to
move my knight from b1 is it time to
move the bishop and so he goes for the
development
don't be fooled by this plus 1.5 because
it's
it's so hard to even understand why that
is
uh i i actually don't even fully
understand why it's possible
like give black two moves right black is
fine
i wonder if he follows up with oh now he
is pointing out that the e5 pawn could
be taken but he should have seen the
move before
now black has enough pieces defending
the pawn
yes exactly literally i mean like if he
if he he just saw that his knight he
didn't like that his name but that's
okay
yeah black has no threats pawn takes
pawn and and black is destroyed on the e
file
yes it's a bit too late now by the e5
pawn i wonder if he will notice that
even though he missed the chance there
he could for instance play knight to e4
or bishop to e4
and try to attack the d6 pawn that's a
vulnerable spot to a weak pawn
is that even considered an inter met so
like before you take on e5 i guess it is
right
so yeah a very strong intermediate move
which removes the defender of the e5
bishop so
danielle would be winning at least a
piece if not more material bishop takes
queen takes knight takes e5 also attacks
then the queen and the bishop on d3
this is suddenly falling apart
unfortunately for rubies but then daniel
plays f6
bishop he i think he he also got tunnel
vision there
thinking that he needs to make sure that
the g7 bishop cannot be traded so he
didn't see that he had an opportunity
that's like a roller coaster just and
then back up and are we about to go back
down again anna
i'm really scared it's actually very
natural here for ruby's to either move
his bishop two squares where it was and
or one squared forward and attacked the
rook so i don't i think we're
fine i don't think we're or that yes a
bishop to d4 very logical
anna you're right oh you take this with
the knight
his chance it's a game where they both
i feel like are a bit too cautious and
instead of realizing that the e4 pawn
was okay to take danielle goes back to
f7
defensive move and this is winning for
oh g4 just g4 right or knight d3 and
some sort of g4
g4 was gonna undermine the d4 bishop but
after the trade now the queen is
defending the d4 bishop so
the pawn push to g4 no longer wins a
piece for danielle
what an exciting game the evaluation bar
dancing to to the beats of rubius
and this isn't anyone's anyone's game
type of position anyone can win this
this is an insane game this is an
extremely high level game of chess and
it is taking place
on the only three open files daniel
don't play rook c1
that does not work also anna do you take
on e5 or do you push
f5 f4 like what are you doing here
probably a five or four feet like he
should push f5 but it's not an
easy decision to take because it allows
white to keep that pawn which would have
been a passport and rookie six is
logical pinning the pawn very good move
that is a classy move so i was right he
does put the queen behind the rook
looking for the better oh my gosh he's
all in
he's all in here this is me i'm telling
you rubies has watched too many of our
champions tour coverage
but you're you're you're like it sounds
like we're joking but he's he like he
might actually be
taking inspiration because so much of
modern chess now is i'm not joking at
all
h4 has happened so many times and he was
watching the broadcast every day
oh this is almost a blunder breaking the
rook with a tempo
he knows about he knows about the
creating a bigger threat concept but
i'm not sure he realized that after
pontix bishop his queen two is hanging
it's that's uh that oh my oh what are
you blowing
it's it twice just just take it daniel
on time daniel has been super capture
averse
this whole game but he has the time to
find it
he's been avoiding a lot of trades yeah
no this is his chance this is his chance
to
calmly calculate that that bishop is
attacked by two oh what he misses
rubius follows up with the king side
attack the basics bishop is still
hanging
it's just immortal it's standing there
and daniel might realize that that's the
thing but now you're being attacked on
the other side and he finds it
he takes it the queen very smart
decision because it forces the queen
trade rubius
with the smiler that he missed the the
bishop hanging
which unfortunately is another piece and
dania will take it that's
i think it's a lot more obvious that
this knife is hanging
oh my oh ruby is just
melting under time pressure
unfortunately he played he was
exceptional
i mean this is three straight games yeah
but he's just
it was a brilliant game by both goodness
daddy didn't take the night so rubius is
still in the game it's a piece down but
he still has some chances
that's a great move because if the king
moves the bishop on f7 is hanging
bishop of eight knight d7 goodness me uh
how
how can dania get out of this then i
don't know
i don't know i think he has to i don't
even know what the best move is
oh he might have seen seven bishop
bishop d4 yep and
i don't even know what's going on oh and
he is he trying to rescue his knight
i think that's what he's doing but now
rook h6 wins the night
yeah wow that's heartbreaking and daniel
the bishop and the rook are attacking it
so just
one move short of getting the knight out
of a
desperate situation yeah daniel
is is is confident in uh in the end game
plus it helps that the other guy's got
20 seconds
let's put it make it very clear and uh
keep converting rubios at two seconds
and there
the defense of the rook is gone
i think he's trying to create a
stalemate i was oh my gosh
i was teaching him about stalemates and
he
he thought it's unfair that someone with
the material up would
make only half a point but i pointed out
that
you always need to make moves in this
case there's no stalemate because
there's still so much room for the king
that
ruby has resigned
oh i knew this was gonna happen
he said i was gonna go danish and okay
let's you know what i'm actually gonna
say this and i'm gonna say
we didn't prepare anything let's see how
the opening goes so that you haven't
prepared for this
no no no no no only if it goes well did
we prepare if it goes poorly it's his
fault
i wonder what development rubios will go
for because i showed him them
no please though i hope it's a mass slip
because i told him that the f7 pawn is
glued to the board i told him you cannot
move that pawn
no well what is going on he's he's
coming up with inspiration so the
dangerous thing here
oh daniel doesn't go d4 daniel
d4 they're shredding it all open all
right we got a game then this actually
might be brilliant by rubios
yeah that was not my prep
i'm gonna distance myself from that i'm
gonna hire a legal team
i i i did not tell daniel negron to play
the move g4 let's just be very clear you
have me on record
uh this is court uh you can admit this
testimony in court i did not
i didn't but having said that rubius
very creatively
comes up with f6 e5 like and
he's fine he's fine and he's playing
faster
g4 was very brave oh daniel and placing
his king on the long diagonal
is also maybe a bit too challenging
for for his own safety
yeah all right listen daniel you can't
be all loosey-goosey having a sandwich i
mean
when c5 has played rubius is storming
back
like this is crazy he's playing
fantastic now daniel's d4 move is not
even possible
he can't go kg3 please don't go king g3
e4 you resign
don't even think about it it's right
there
in the line of sight oh f5 is so good
what a move by rubius opening up the f5
is
if daniel realizes that he has to
safeguard his king with one of the
pieces that's going to be under attack
he can actually stabilize for example
pawn takes bishop
here bishop takes and like queen takes
and daniel might
like he's not it's not good
but it's not dead lost or even knight
takes
even knight takes is good the other move
that rubios is looking at is bishop e5 i
think that's a strong one too and
eventually he settles with f4 that was
one of his first
thoughts he doesn't realize how
important e4 is to his attack he needs
e4 to guard f3 and if daniel takes e4
with literally anything although some
are better than others
yeah black's attack is almost completely
gone if if daniel plays knight d e4 and
bishop f3
and he's played it and now bishop f3 and
he's stabilized
yeah so now i would expect bishop g4
but that actually allows the rook to
take the pawn right now the rook is
guarded
that the pawn is guarded but yeah bishop
g4 reopens the pin
i don't know if we're going to get rook
g5 but
he just goes all in six all in
daniel what are you doing
he's so brave this game the funny thing
is
if if 20 moves from here on we gonna get
an end game where there's a backrank
checkmate thanks to the g6 pawn it could
still
work out in danielle's favor but he has
to survive
this stage of the game because now his
king will be
again the target and the black king is
safer now it's important to remember
that the rook is hanging so this
this is important to remember why
that's an exchange sacrifice i don't
think volunteers
yeah he forgot it's hanging but it's
still a game
it is still a game even if he loses the
rook for the bishop
oh he doesn't realize
uh daniel's blunder the bishop well will
rubio see it
will he just move the king or will he
see that the bishop is hanging
right that's the thing because he he
thinks oh it's over i just got to play
some moves and that's it and he's going
to kill me and he's he might be
and he spots it he spots it it's game on
we move the king and then he takes the
bishop
he wants to get rid of that
94 is a good idea oh that's a good idea
in fact it's so good it just wins
goodness me that's that's a killer move
if he plays it
oh he thinks he's inside he's winning
need to move you need to move
well that that was not that was not
spanish
oh he missed no
oh no a mouse slip in a crucial moment
i i i feel so bad
but now the rook is hanging daniel's
hanging his rook but rubio doesn't see
it he doesn't have time
oh are we gonna get queenie four night
h4 queen eight mate is rubio's gonna see
this oh ruby's ruby is rubios no
rubius rubius the background checkmate
levy have i told you about the g6 spawn
earlier
the funny thing is if if 20 moves from
here on we're gonna get an
end game where there's a back rank
checkmate thanks to the g64 anna you
were right
i didn't know you're all right i didn't
want to be right
i didn't want to be right
my heart is broken i'm relieved because
he played so good and i think honestly
if he had more time he probably would
have won both games right because like
honestly and early i'm like okay
no problem here i'm good and all of a
sudden what and then when i was white i
was just going to march up the right
side
he's doing stuff on the left i'm not
paying attention nothing matters and
before i know it
boom boom boom boom boom he's attacking
like every area
and i realized like i was all crammed in
and had nowhere to move so
like luckily at the end he only had like
20 seconds or something and i you know
he blundered his queen and a couple
things there but
if he had more time i don't see how i
was i don't know how i was gonna win
from white there but after i screwed all
that up gave away a
freaking what'd i give away i gave away
a free knife my problem was
today that since my matches from
yesterday or
or two days ago with xqc i now have
trust issues many many trust issues
because
when i played against xqc and i didn't
see
the check-in ones and stuff like that
that took a lot of confidence from me
when
i played today so not knowing what to do
and that's
why i think that i took more time to
play
uh today because the other day i was
playing
much quicker but today i was like
watching at the clock and it was
just like 20 seconds to finish the game
and i
started getting nervous and stuff and
yeah he
he also played really good like he was
always
attacking everything i had like so many
stuff planned
in my head and then when i was about to
do the plan and finish it and win the
game he was there and
stopped everything all my plans so yeah
ggs man
really good games
[Music]
you